[Music]
every little girl would love to live in
a fairy tale and some women did in the
best or the worst way make sure you
watch this video and tell the end to
know what really happened to Pocahontas
we can't believe that Disney made us
believe that it was a love story if you
love Disney Princesses as much as we do
don't forget to subscribe and please
give this video a big thumbs up today we
are showing you 10 of Disney princes
stories in real life Beauty and the
Beast the popular Disney movie was
actually based on a real-life couple
that lived back in the 1500s and yes
there was a beast even though he
wouldn't like you to call him that at
that time people with interesting
characteristics were really popular in
royal courts Patras Gonsalves suffered
from an extremely rare condition called
hypertrichosis this is why his whole
body was covered with belongs to care
and thanks to his unique trait he was
sent to King Henry the second court
people can ask him the man of the woods
to bear his teeth and act savage but
Patras was not interested in this role
and always remains calm this is probably
one of the reasons why the king gave him
the opportunity to become a nobleman by
giving him a wardrobe makeover and a
quality education the only other thing
he needed was a wife and the Queen made
finding him a wife her personal mission
a woman named Catherine wasn't scared of
him and was quickly seduced by his
personality unlike Belle in the Disney
movie they were married for 40 years and
even had seven children three of them
were born with hypertrichosis just like
their father it's true that looks don't
matter but we should tell the Beast in
the Disney movie that you still need to
work on your personality Sleeping Beauty
if you study or work too much you
probably wish that you could live in a
fairytale life like Sleeping Beauty you
just sleep all the time until the love
of your life is there to wake you up and
you live happily ever after
unfortunately when it happens in the
real life things just get weird for an
art exhibition in Ukraine five
attractive young women slept one by one
at the gallery they even promised that
they would marry anyone who wakes them
up with their kiss both the women and
the participants had to sign a contract
so they better live happily ever after
for real the artists who worked on this
project hottest bullet Eiko said that
the idea behind it
patience while beauty is sleeping the
entire kingdom is also sleeping if the
kingdom is to be woken to Beauty must be
woken
however when Jana Garza opened her eyes
she was not facing a prince but a
princess was she dreaming she couldn't
believe her eyes unfortunately as
ukraine didn't allow gay marriage the
two girls couldn't tie the knot but that
didn't keep them from being friends the
princess said that she believes that it
was not a coincidence that they had to
meet this way she thought that the girl
was a very interesting person and she
hopes that they'll have some kind of
professional and creative partnership we
can still call this a happily ever after
tangled no we didn't find a woman with
hair that can magically turn an older
witch into a young woman or kill
injuries but we did find someone who
could compete with Rapunzel when you see
how long her hair is according to the
Guinness World Records the longest
documented hair belongs to she equipping
in May 2004 it was recorded that her
hair was more than 18 feet in a half
long and more than 5.6 meters that's
nearly as long as the height of a
giraffe she has been growing her hair
since 1973 when she was 13 years old if
you hate brushing your hair or having it
stuck in your zipper or under your
armpit you can't even imagine what she
is going through but no matter what she
has said that her hair is no trouble at
all and she is used to it however she
said that you need patience and to hold
yourself straight when you have hair
like this we don't know what she is up
to now but if she didn't cut her hair we
can believe that it's even longer
however she is far from Rapunzel whose
hair was 70 feet long in the Disney
movie let's just stick to real records
and not try to compete with characters
in movies there is no way Rapunzel could
have lived with so much hair on her head
Snow White a German scholar named
eckardt sander thinks that Snow White's
story isn't completely made up that's
because the life of a woman was so
similar to what the Disney character
went through that she might have been
the one who inspired the fairy tale
Marguerite's von Waldeck was a german
countess but was forced by her
stepmother to move away when she was
only 16 years old this is when she fell
in love with the prince who would later
become philip ii of spain and her
stepmother was really
the king of Spain and the stepmother
didn't want the two lovers to get
married a king saw it as an
inconvenience for the nation while the
stepmother didn't really have a good
reason but you can guess what it was and
to get rid of the poor Marguerite they
decided to poison her but things get
even weirder when you look at other
similarities Snow White was actually
blind in the original story he jests
like Marguerite's she also lived in a
place where children were called Dwarfs
because of their height and used to work
in mines no one knows if she was the
most beautiful woman in the kingdom or
if her stepmother tried to poison her
with an apple but we still think that
the two stories are really similar and
I'll have to stay tuned to see another
real-life Snow White on our list
Cinderella who said that fairy tales
couldn't come true this young woman was
the living proof that you can live a
Cinderella story in real life in June
2017 Chad Michael Murray from a
Cinderella story was heading to prom to
meet his princess for the night his wife
Sarah Romer looked more beautiful than
ever for the Children's Hospital's Alice
in Wonderland themed prom this is why
the actor knew that she needed to have a
real Prince Charming by her side
he asked to Warner Brothers
entertainment to let him wear his famous
ensemble from a Cinderella story once
again and they said yes he was surprised
to see that it still fit and this is how
we saw Austin Ames come back to life 13
years later Sarah said on Twitter that
she waited for her prince and he took
her to her first prom it was years after
she finished high school but we think
that waiting is worth it when you end up
with a man like Chad Michael Murray the
story doesn't tell if Sarah lost his
shoe when she left the hospital at
midnight but we hope that Chad didn't
take too much time to find his wife
after prom who said that only teenagers
could live a fairytale story
grown-ups deserve to be happily ever
after - it's better late than never
Milan the popular Disney movie was based
on The Ballad of Hugh a Mulan which is
the legend of a warrior woman who
brought hope to China it's hard to
believe but she was even better than the
Disney character herself as she already
knew how to fight when she joined the
army
and stayed there for a couple more years
however no one knows if Mulan
we existed or not this is why we had to
come up with another famous crossdresser
who joined the army Joan of Arc she was
a French girl who began having mystical
visions that encouraged her to lead a
pious life over time she learned to
better understand them and was named the
savior of France she was so confident
that she went to see the Dauphin Charles
and asked if she could expel the English
and make him the rightful king as a test
he hid in a crowd of members of his
court and he was surprised to see that
the young woman correctly identified him
Joan was so popular that he gave her a
horse and a few soldiers Joan then cut
her hair and dressed in men's clothing
for her journey long story short she won
the battle unfortunately she didn't live
happily ever after
as she was burned at the stake after a
tribunal announced that she was guilty
of heresy
Aladin did you know that jasmine was so
beautiful that the animators had to
redesign Aladdin he was really handsome
at the beginning but they knew they had
to make him look better when they saw
who he was supposed to fall in love with
and we clearly understand this when we
take a look at jasmine in real life the
whole world was seduced by model olenka
mia noel when she posted these pictures
on instagram she wasn't only dressed as
jasmine she looks just like her twin it
was posted on Halloween and we don't
think anyone can compete with her we
don't even understand how she did that
hair
she even recreated one of the most
iconic musical numbers from the movie
with her friends Aladdin they sang a
whole new world together and this moment
couldn't be more perfect except for the
fact that she kind of forced him even
when she's not wearing her Halloween
costume this Queen looks just like the
Disney character in a modern world there
is only one explanation the Disney
couple wish they could discover a whole
new world and this is when the genie
gave them a chance to visit our universe
as long as too far is not there with
them we are totally okay with that it's
just like they made our wish come true
to Snow White
we found another Snow White in our world
and this one officially inspired the
princess that we saw in the Disney movie
marge champion was only 14 years old
just like the princess when she
auditioned for Disney animators she
wasn't going to be the voice of the
princess but actually her movements as
they wanted to capture the characters
graceful motion to do their drawings her
father was a day
choreographer who taught her how to
dance and be an elegant lady so all the
other girls didn't stand a chance at
first they put a helmet on her head
while she danced to illustrate a larger
head of the character but it was so hot
underneath and she was so limited that
she almost fainted then they tried again
without that big hat there was no
choreography and they just let Marge do
whatever she wanted she was making it up
and the animators were inspired by her
movements to draw the Disney princess
but Marge
also inspired other characters like
dopey when she danced like him they put
a big coat on her and asked her to do
funny things just like the door you
might not recognize her face but every
child has seen a large champion could
dance and she will be remembered forever
as the inspiration for Snow White's
Sleeping Beauty we found another
Sleeping Beauty but unfortunately this
fairy tale doesn't end well the mirror
reported that Nicole only 20 years old
suffers from the Sleeping Beauty
syndrome also called the kleine-levin
syndrome when she falls asleep she just
can't wake up and this is not as fun as
you think she is not just linked to
school every day during one episodes she
actually slept for 64 days straight and
even when she is awake she doesn't
understand what is happening and can't
even recognize her family members all
she can do is eat and go to the bathroom
it all started when she was only 6 years
old she was sleeping up to 18 hours a
day and her mother thought that she just
had the flu or something like that it
took 25 months to get the diagnosis and
even now that she knows what she is
suffering from there is no cure her
episodes now lasts anywhere between 22
and 64 days straight and she has no
control over it it means that she also
miss important moments of her life like
Christmas birthdays proms and family
members facts only 1000 people in the
world have this condition and they still
don't know what to do about it
think twice before wishing that you
could be sleeping all the time even true
love's kiss can't cure that Pocahontas
this time Disney clearly wanted to base
its movie on a young woman who really
existed and they totally failed no one
should ever think that this is a love
story when Pocahontas was treated like
Savage the daughter of the chief was
actually named Mitaka Pocahontas was
only a nickname which meant the naughty
child she was only a child when she met
John Smith so we really hoped that they
were not in love with each other
sparks didn't fly between them and there
is no proof that she ever tried to save
him as Smith told this story years after
it happened Pocahontas was taken
prisoner when she was only 17 and held
hostage for more than a year another
John John Rolfe was interested in her
and said that she could be released as
long as she agreed to marry him
Mitaka became Rebecca Wolfe and had a
child named Thomas the family then
returned to England where the Native
American had become a celebrity
unfortunately she passed away at age 21
and never lived happily ever after
we think that portraying John Smith as
the good guy was an insult to the poor
young woman who actually suffered for
all these years if you could live one
disney princess story in real life which
one would it be don't be shy to answer
in the comment section down below we'd
love to hear what you think and that's
it for 10 disney princess stories in
real life for more stories like this
make sure you watch 10 strange
requirements to work as a Disney
Princess thanks for watching and see you
next time
[Music]